I was on a train in New York and looking
at Twitter and somebody had posted an
article that caused the dime to drop for
me with respect to mixed martial arts
and why they were suddenly a thing in my
life where they hadn't been I had
assumed that it was simply the fact that
I'd showed up on your podcast and
obviously you're in that world and so a
certain number of mixed martial arts
people were now following me and I was
seeing their their tweets and things but
this guy I think his name is John kirbo
posted an article that he had written
about Bruce Lee and his argument did you
see this article the argument was why
Bruce Lee and mixed martial arts points
the direction to how to fix our
political dialogue something huh and so
anyway his argument was and you you know
I'm no expert on this at all but his
argument was that Bruce Lee effectively
the the innovator at the beginning of
mixed martial arts was interested in
testing a martial art against all comers
rather than requiring the person on the
other side to be practicing the same
martial art and that there is a kind of
model in that for other disciplines than
any any time if your debate style
requires somebody to be debating in the
same way on the other side of the
argument then it isn't very strong right
then it's a formalism but if you're
really good at arguing then it shouldn't
really matter as long as the person
speaks the same language you should be
able to meet them on that playing field
and hash stuff out so anyway I I think a
number of things linked up in this way
that there is a kind of artificial
boundary placed between things and that
those who are interested in tearing down
those boundaries even though that opens
up a huge range of things that they may
face often have something to teach in
their particular realm